hello everyone and welcome to another
very enjoyable game to watch uh it's a
vidit gujarati versus nils grandelus
from the masters edition we've checked
out the game in the previous video from
the challengers section if you guys
haven't seen it do check it out it's a
very very enjoyable features a beautiful
checkmate but now we turn to the game
that can only be described as a true
positional masterpiece uh and um
the masterpiece could have been
prevented maybe
but
you really have to find the move that's
not easily uh found and
there was more than one occasion
throughout the game where it could have
been played but not spoiled too much uh
let's check it out and then we're gonna
discuss it a little bit uh d4 is already
on the board so uh vidit opens with the
d4 we have knight to f6 knight to f3 and
now uh well we might transpose into some
sort of a queen's gambit declined or
something but no we have g6 by by nils
and now not c4 or g3 which are the main
moves uh in this uh in this position we
have knight b to d to avid uh grabs hold
of the e4 square and he's ready to grab
the center and advance his e pawn uh all
the way to e4 you could achieve
the same thing with knight to c3 but
then you block your c pawn and that's
not something you want to do in
positions like these so bishop to g7 and
now uh pawn all the way to e4 we have
castles bike rendez inviting vidit to
play e5 so he does we have e5
and now knight to h5 you could also play
knight to d5 uh but this is uh uh sort
of like uh you you'll get like a really
weird uh position that maybe could be
obtained if black doesn't treat the
alien defense very well uh but um uh
well it's just a little bit better but
but it's uh very very very similar so
instead after e5 we have knight to the
h5 this is considered to be
the best line here and now we have g4 uh
if you notice uh there is really no good
square for the knight other than f4 and
the video placing the knight on d2
allows the knights to go to f4 so here
we have g4 challenging the knight knight
to f4 and now knight to e4 and excellent
square for this knight grabbing a lot of
control here over the
d6 and f6 squares and challenging the
knight on f4 so of course uh niels uh
strikes in the center with d5 he says
all right you capture on f4 i'm going to
capture on e4
but now knight to g3 we have knight back
to e6 and now we have knight to f5 a
very nice idea by vidit it's not a new
idea it has been played before uh by uh
someone you know very well uh we're
gonna discuss this in a little bit and
the idea is uh if g captures g captures
then the knight is trapped you don't
really have a square for the knight so
it's not uh it's not really a piece
sacrifice uh we would go into something
like knight captures on the four knight
captures bishop captures an e5 and now
bishop to h6 for example challenging the
rook here white would have a very very
nice attack we would have the the open g
file to use for attack so black would
have a very very hard time defending
this if at all possible maybe it's
possible uh you know on paper or on the
computer but over the board not likely
so grandelus
goes c5 instead challenges the center
here and now we have knight captures on
g7 and the position has been reached
before in a game between andrew tang and
uh
maxim chigav from the bill masters 2021
so it was played last year the game
ended in a draw but here king captures
on g7 was played in this game niels
plays knight captures on g7 and it's now
already as of move tender we have a
completely new game uh so let's see what
vid is prepared the g4 pawn is hanging
so he defends it with h3 and now c
captures on d4
so this is uh
you don't have the capture on d4 and i
often mention this that if you don't uh
gain something by capturing maybe you
shouldn't capture
but here it's it's okay to capture but
it's basically a matter of taste do you
want to what kind of a player you are do
you want to uh play it like this or do
you want to play knight to c6 first
where you are still threatening to
capture and then if white captures on c5
which uh you know i'm not a fan of then
you can advance d4 and it becomes a
different type of game but okay here we
have c captures on d4 and now not
recapturing we can always recapture
bishop to h6 so not allowing this knight
to move anywhere the rook would be
captured
and here we have queen to a5 with check
black says all right you've played
this very nicely you've surprised me but
now you are in check and how do you play
this you can play c3 because now my pawn
is very useful here you can play queen
here but then i trade the queens off and
your attack is over or you can play king
to e2 but that's not i mean uh you do
not want to block your queen and bishop
in one move so here with it place queen
to d2 we have queen capture sunday to
knight captures on d2 and now uh we have
knight to c6 uh you could also consider
a move like f5 but uh uh well that
that's uh something to be considered as
the white king is still in the center of
the board you don't really mind captures
captures it's uh maybe a nice nice move
to play but okay here we have knight to
c6 and now what did the divided gain
from all of this will he plays f4 and
now he has this monster chain here on
the king side and it's not going to be
all that easy for black to develop so
black challenges the structure right
away he plays f6 e captures on f6 we
have e captures and now queen side
castles pivot we have rook to e8 finally
allowing the knights to move
and now what do you play here well to
keep advantage probably rook to g1 or
bishop to g2 should be played as those
moves will be played at some point but
here we have knight to b3 and this
knight the b3 move allows uh
allows neil's a devious idea that was
missed in the game so just for fun uh
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible um incredible move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's bishop to f5 now that you see
it i'm sure you even believe it the idea
is that uh
well the bishop on h6 is unguarded and
we can we can trap it but first we have
to trap our own bishop and now the point
is if white accepts the bishop then we
just play knight captures on f5 we've
ruined white's pawn structure on the
king side and we're gonna capture the
bishop on the next move there's no way
for for white to avoid this however if
after bishop to f5 white tries bishop
captures on g7 first then it seems like
okay now if captures we've just
blundered the bishop but there's bishop
to e4 uh also you had to notice that
white's rooks are not connected so
that's always a problem and then uh
because you know it's very principled to
connect your rooks if your rooks are not
connected then your opponent gets some
very nice tactics and you might run into
something like this so that's why i
mentioned that maybe rook to g1 or
bishop the g2 prior to that knights to
b3 idea were preferable but okay here
you would play rook to g1 for example
king captures on g7 and everything is
perfectly fine for black you've
developed your bishop which is your most
which was your most problematic piece
but after knight to b3 uh niels missed
this he played knight to e6 first and
now uh avid just allows uh a video just
continues development with bishop to g2
yo you could also start with the f5
first uh he wants to play bishop to g2
and then f5 okay bishop to g2
we have knight the c7 and now he strikes
with f5 now f5 is also
uh well uh for example g captures on f5
you do not capture back but rather you
play rook h to f1 now you put pressure
on this f5 pawn and you're asking black
to capture it but if black captures on
g4 then we play rook captures on f6 the
other rook comes to f1 and it's gonna be
very very difficult uh
to avoid all of these threats for the
black king you always have to keep an
eye on that d5 pawn your knight will not
be able to move from from uh c7 so it's
a it's an ugly position for black so
instead after rook h2 f1 we have king to
f7 uh and now g captures on f5 so uh
still it's not easy to develop this
bishop and well just think that it could
have been developed a few moves ago with
that bishop to f5 idea so rook the g8
putting pressure on the bishop here rook
to d2 defending and then now comes
knight to e5 uh but we have to go back
one move we're gonna remove this knight
from e5 back to c6 and now there is
again a move that niels can play and it
is again believe it or not bishop
captures an f5 so we have to give up
this bishop and
again use the idea that the bishop on h6
is stranded so we have to play bishop
captors on f5 rook captures and king to
g6 to win our uh the bishop back and
then after
rouge goes back rook back to f2 we're
going to capture on h6 rook captures
here for example rogue goes here and uh
well we're still up a pawn as black we
are you know
we're having a nice game so uh not
missing bishop captures on f5 once but
now missing it again we have knight to
e5 by nils and now knight captures on d4
and now after this capture the f5 pawn
is now sufficiently defended and it is
not easy for for black to find them
bishop to d7 you have to develop this
bishop somehow now comes b3 we're going
to control all of the light squares so
black cannot use them we have rook a to
e8 now comes a4
we have a6 now bishop to f4 finally
getting this bishop out of that silly
square and now going after the knight on
c7 so now the knight and e5 cannot move
as this knight would hang so rook to e7
we want to move our bishop so the knight
is protected and now rook f2 f2 now
vidit now has all the time in the world
and he will now improve his position as
much as possible before he continues uh
the rampaging rampaging with his king
with something like this but uh first of
course we were
we're gonna have to trade off some
pieces you can just rush in with your
king with you know the other half of the
board full of enemies pieces so here
bishop to c6 and now king to b2 we have
rooked a d7 uh we need to defend the d5
pawn because white will very easily
attack it many times king the a3 and now
knight to e8 uh preparing to to shift
the knight maybe to g7 maybe to d6 but
now comes c4 and this is a beautiful
move by visit
as it uh really shows how how difficult
black's position is so black can't
really move any of the pieces and uh
well there's the simple thread of just
removing uh the defender of the d5 pawn
then pawn captures okay it defends it
again but then c captures on d5 we have
more than enough attackers to win a pawn
here and gain a
better position and the other thing is
if you play d captures on c4 which is
kind of well obvious we have to we have
to see what happens here then you just
lose a piece knight captures on c6 rook
captures on d2 knight captures and e5
now comes with check f captures on e5
and now bishop captures on d2 that's the
point and if you count the pieces we are
up a full bishop
so after the c4 move uh knight to g7 was
played now even though knight the c7
still kind of holds the d5 pawn and the
vidit would have to figure out a
different um a different game plan of
course he would just continue with what
he was doing all the time but it would
be the the most resilient way to go i
guess the position is still winning for
white we would see something like bishop
to f1 uh and then after black makes a
move uh let's say a5 we're gonna play c5
and then uh well we can just play bishop
to b5 or knight to b5 and it's going to
be again very very hard for black to
withstand all this pressure but in the
game knight to g7 was played and now
it's a pretty straightforward win c
captures on d5 or rather not yet first
knight captures on c6 uh b captures on
c6 and now just c characters on d5 and
now the problem is look at the king and
the rook here uh if you play c captures
on d5 we can just play bishop captures
on d5 with check or even better rook
captures on d5 this is uh unstoppable
and now if real captures we're going to
play bishop captures and you can defend
this you can't block with the knight
because of the pawn here so after the
king moves we just pick up the rook and
it's a game over uh
whatever you you try uh let's say king
to f8 we're gonna well we can even trade
off the bishop for for night then pick
up the rook or or pick up the rook then
pick up this and we're just gonna be up
the exchange uh in a winning end game so
instead after c captures on d5 rook uh g
to d8 was played now putting pressure on
the d5 pawn also preparing maybe to
capture on d2 but it's not uh really a
useful move as the rook on d2 is
sufficiently defended so here uh vidi
just played the d captures on c6 and he
was in this position on move 34 uh that
niels grandelius resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
so of course if you trade then it's
completely winning rook captures and now
it doesn't matter what you do captures
captures king e7 you go after the pawn
we just play bishop to e4 we defend our
pawn here on f5 we are up two pawns of
course it's completely winning for
uh for for white and it's a bishop pair
against two knights and since the game
is on both sides of the board the
bishops are much much stronger since
they control the entire board and the
knights have to hop around a few moves
to reach the other side of the board uh
you know so there's also that and
another thing here if you don't trade
you could play something like rook to d3
to try and keep the rooks on the board
but now rook captures knight captures
and now even rook to d2 is enough for a
win c7 is coming there's nothing you can
do to stop this for example knight
captures an f5 c7 now rook to c8 and
just rook captures on d3 uh we pick up a
piece and we are completely winning even
our pawn is defended here so we don't
even care about that
yeah now after d captures on c6
aggrandel is resigned and what a
brilliant victory for vidit uh
in this uh crazy crazy game uh but as
you've seen every positional masterpiece
uh
can be can be averted uh if you find the
uh the correct idea
and here i'm just going to show it to
one more time
after knight to b3 just bishop to f5 in
this position looks silly but the bishop
on h6 is um
is uh well just stranded and i believe
here bishop to f5 was much harder to see
than the the than the other time uh
because you also have to you know uh
uh you even if you think about bishop to
f5 you're gonna think to yourself okay
but then just bishop captures on g7 and
i'll lose the bishop but you also have
to see bishop to e4 and then again
here after
all this was played rook to d2 again
bishop captures an f5 you just give up
the the bishop for for king to g6 and in
the double attack against the rook and
the bishop so really really impressive
stuff but uh niels missed it and that
was more than enough for vidi to create
this beautiful beautiful uh uh
positional masterpiece
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it here are the standings uh
that's those are not the standings
that's anish
um
so these are the the standings and uh uh
the standings after eight rounds have
been played uh the leaders are magnus
carlson and shakhtar and mamadara with
five and a half points and they will
meet uh in round nine uh to see who will
take the lead in the tournament then
with five points we have anish giri and
jirati with four and a half rihard
rapport uh with four points andrea
sipenko fabiano corona sergey karyakin
with three and a half young sister of
duda and sam shanklin with three daniel
dubov after that misfortune of
throwing basically the game against uh
anish uh prague with two and a half and
niels with two points so we'll see we'll
see what happens next plenty more games
uh uh to see in the tata still i hope
you guys are enjoying the coverage so
far so yeah once again i hope you
enjoyed this i would like to thank david
kimura thomas earl trevor furtado souza
gwyn guo khan and william rose for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of this spectacular event until
it finishes thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day